Hey everyone, this is the third in a
trilogy of videos with Grant Sanderson
from 3Blue1Brown about sequences that
don't necessarily do what you'd expect.
Links to the first two videos are on the screen
and in the video description; you don't have to
have watched them to understand this one but you
may want to watch them to get the full experience.
The way this is gonna work, um we're gonna have a
race between prime numbers, okay. And we're going
to have two different categories: those which are
1 mod 4, meaning when you divide by 4 they leave
a remainder of 1, and those which are 3 mod
4. And we're basically just going to count up
the prime numbers. So the first one is 2, and 2 is
disqualified from the race because it's the oddest
prime, it doesn't really fit into the pattern of
the rest, it's the only one that's even. Next uh
we've got 3 and then the next one is 5 and then
the next prime is 7. 7 is 3 above a multiple
of 4; and then 11 is also 3 above a multiple of
4. And then the next one 13 is just 1 above a
multiple of 4, and then the next one, 17. So they
seem pretty neck and neck so far as we're kind of
counting up. So after 17 we've got 19, which is
3 above a multiple of 4, and then 23 which is 3
above a multiple of 4. And then the next one will
be 29, and then after that we're going to have 31,
37. And one thing you might notice is that
so far in the whole race, even though it's
pretty neck and neck, team 3 has always been
in the lead so far. And you might say, okay,
that seems maybe just kind of at random that that
would be the case; but actually if we continue
this race - and if you want I can give you some
visuals that like show the race continuing on -
- (Brady: Do you know someone) (who's
good at making mathematics visuals?)
- I I cancall a guy. But uh
it will be- it'll always be 3
who seems to be in the lead. And you know they're
pretty close, they're a pretty even balanced like
you might expect; but if it was completely
random, if it was just random which bucket
you're tossing it into you wouldn't expect such a
long streak for there to be a particular winner.
And in fact it continues going on until the
first time that team 1 mod 4 is gonna break into
the lead is going to happen at the prime 26,861.
But even then the next prime after that is going
to be 26,863. So that was just one brief moment
of peeking into the lead and then after that they
do stay in the lead quite a bit longer, team
3 mod 4. And then the next time that team 1 is
able to get ahead is going to happen at 616,841.
And it keeps the lead a little bit longer then
but then 3 takes over. And if you're looking at
most of the numbers, most of the time it seems
like- you know 99% of the time the team that's
in the lead is team 3. And this was actually
a conjecture that someone made that said: is
it the case that as we let n tend to infinity
and we consider at all of the points of the
race, how often was it the case that team 3
was in the lead? Does that percentage of the
time approach a 100%? Interesting question.
You might expect it to be true, if there's
any reason that there should be more 3s then
you might expect it to either fall, you know,
completely 50/50 or completely to 100%. But,
you know, I think the question I'd like
to talk about a little is why would you
expect something like this to happen?
It feels like the prime shouldn't have
a bias one way or another, um why does
this team get any kind of advantage?
- (Well primes do have a bias, they
have a bias towards odd numbers )
Fair point, okay, so there's a very
strong bias towards odd numbers;
um and maybe you're on to something there that we
shouldn't treat primes so randomly. But often you
have this criteria that's once you rule out
the obvious things that primes aren't going
to do, the things based on divisibility
constraints, their behavior feels random.
And this this heuristic actually helps people
make a lot of conjectures and a lot of it kind
of susses out- uh turns out to be true once
you delve into it. And so something like
this- another one um that's in in same vein,
let's say we look at the last digits of the
primes. Is it going to be a 1? Is it going
to be a 3? Is it going to be a 7 or is it
going to be a 9? If you perform that race, as
you do that longer and longer they all tend to
be about 25% of the time, but two of them are
distinguished winners. They tend to be winning
the race even if it's just by a little bit. So
in the long run it tends to be about 25% percent
of them primes end in a 1 but there is just this
gentle bias. And you might ask why; okay there's
a very- you say the biased to be odd, there's a
very clear reason they're like strongly biased
to be odd. What is the what is the reason then
that 3 mod 4 would have this kind of advantage?
- (You have- so are you) (confirming to me
that it does have an advantage? Is it- has
that conjecture been proven or?) That's- that's
a really interesting question which we will get
to at the end of the video actually. That- for
the moment let's just consider that conjecture
something that has strong empirical suggestiveness
um but it's very tricky to prove that kind of
thing and then the answer is surprising and we
will get to it. Ah, here's a question of how
much detail we want to go into. I think this is
a pretty satisfying intuition, if you're willing
to take on faith one magical fact that I present
to you. So the story is going to start outside of
here but instead with a formula a lot of people
might know for pi of all things: 1 over 1 minus
1 over 3 plus 1 over 5 minus 1 over 7... So I'm
basically toggling whether I add or subtract,
and I'm going over all of the odd numbers.
So this isn't primes, it's all of the odd
numbers that I'm doing. In fact I'm going
to give a name to let it be kind of clear,
this plus minus pattern where I'm going to make
up a function that seems needlessly complicated
right now that I'm going to call chi of n. And
basically chi of n is going to be defined to be
+1 if n is 1 mod 4, it's going to be -1 when n
is 3 mod 4, and then I could maybe say that it's
0 you know if n is even. And so basically what
we're doing is we're adding up chi of n divided
by n. Overly fancy way of saying, I'm toggling
between plus and minus on the odd numbers, but
it's it's nice to have a name for that function
for what we get to in a moment. Now some people
might know that this actually converges, if you
look at this on the number line you have your 1,
you subtract back a little bit to 1/3,
plus 1/5, minus 1/7 - and I can even draw
that out a little bit if we want. We've got 1,
and if we subtract 1/3 you land somewhere here,
if we add 1/5, you know, because that step is
smaller we don't quite get to that 1. And then
if we subtract 1/7 that step was smaller still and
so you'll basically be bouncing back and forth.
You know you're going to converge to something
and the value you converge to is pi-fourths. That
is actually not important for where we're going
but the fact that it's a number- it's going to
be something. Who doesn't love pi right? Right now
pi is almost just like an imposter into our story,
it doesn't really have much of importance other
than the fact that it's something. Now the magical
fact, the absolute magical fact, is the number
theorists favorite way to take a logarithm.
And it works like this, we're going to take our
series - and in order for this trick to work,
there's just a couple criteria the series has
to have. There's got to be a number associated
with every natural number, so we might think of 0s
for all of the evens here, um and then it has to
have the property that when I multiply the terms
associated with two numbers like 3 and 5 that the
product of the terms corresponds to the product
of those numbers. So in this case 3 times 5 is
15 and negative 1/3 times positive 1/5 is indeed
negative 1/15. It's not exactly obvious but this
will hold no matter which ones you look at. So for
example if we take 1/7 and 1/3: negative 1/7 times
negative 1/3 will be positive 1/21. And if we go-
it would be a positive 1/21. So as long as that
property holds you can do this magical thing
to take a logarithm, where I'm going to say,
I don't like composite numbers, I'm going to kick
out my composite numbers. If you're not prime
um either you're not going to be in the club or
you're going to get a strong punishment based
on how not prime you are. So 1 we don't
like you, 1 gets kicked out entirely.
1/3 you get to stay. So your term
gets to stay, 1/5 you get to stay,
1/7 you get to stay. 1/9 we say okay,
1/9 you're not prime, I don't like you,
but you're just a prime power. At least you
only have one prime factor so you're not as
bad as those dirty composites like 6 or 15. So
we'll let you stay, but because you're the square
of a prime we're going to give you a punishment
by reducing you by 1/2. So it gets to stay but
only half as powerful. And then it goes on: 1/11,
you're prime, you're cool, you get to stay. 1/13,
you're prime, you're cool, you get to stay. 1/15,
not only are you not prime you have two different
prime factors, you're very composite, you're out
of the club entirely. And I'll just do a couple
more to kind of make it clear: we've got 1/17 -
and notice I've got two pluses in a row but that's
because we kind of kicked out the minus. All we
care about is whether this number is 1 mod 4 or 3
mod 4. So I'll be subtracting off 1/19,
I will also be subtracting off 1/23,
because uh 1/21 got kicked out for having too many
factors. 1/25 we're going to have to keep him but
divide him by 2. A way of saying, okay you're not
prime, but you're just a prime power, and because
you're the square of a prime you get reduced. And
just to make this extra clear, the next one that
we see is the cube of a prime, 1/27, so I'm going
to reduce it by 1/3 that gets me 1/ 27. In general
what we're doing here is we're taking 1 over k
times something divided by p to the power of k;
where p is a prime number, k could be anything,
and we're basically taking this chi function of
p to the k. Which is just a way of measuring, are
you plu- are you 1 mod 4 or 3 mod 4? So that might
be how you write this in general.
- (So Grant if this is)
(some kind of shortcut, it's not
feeling like a shortcut but all right)
- So it's it's not a shortcut,
it's just the coolest way-
because if you- okay I do this, I do this
completely random procedure to my series,
and you'd say what is it going to equal?
I don't know, some completely different number
that's completely unrelated to the thing that we
started with. Because you went, primes are such
a random thing that you're hacking them off at
these seemingly random points, you should expect
nothing normal to come from this. But the beauty
is that what you get is just the natural log of
whatever it was before. And um we could do this
with a lot of different things actually: another
famous sequence people might know is if we take 1
over 1 + 1 over 4 + 1 over over 9 and we add
up the reciprocals of all the square numbers. So
we kind of go on and we're always adding up 1
over n squared. This has the property we care about
where when you multiply corresponding terms, what
you get corresponds to their product. If we do the
same game, we kick out some prime numbers, we keep
the prime powers but we reduce them a little bit,
uh it'll again be a logarithm. So this sequence
happens to be pi squared divided by 6, and if we do
our whole like prime number game - whatever we want
to call it - what we'll get will be the natural log
of pi squared over 6. And so that that holds in
general and it's it's the weirdest possible way
to take a logarithm. Why am I talking about this?
The reason is that if we look at the sequence
that we have here; now we have uh mostly primes,
we've got some prime powers in there, but it's
mostly prime numbers and we're kind of adding
or subtracting them and this might give us a
little bit of an indication that if they're
to stay roughly evenly balanced, you know, that
would justify the fact that we're equaling some
constant. Where if there were systematically way
more that are 1 above a multiple of 4 or way
more that are 3 above a multiple of 4, the whole
series might diverge. A couple other magical
facts I'll throw down will be that this series
diverges absolutely, which is a way of saying
if we changed all of the minuses to be pluses
and we just asked, hey I'm going to add up the
sizes of all of these terms, does that converge
to any number? It goes and blows up to infinity.
And what that kind of tells us is if we look at
the camp that are all of the things that are being
added and all the camp that are being subtracted,
both of those blow up to infinity. And so when
we're cutting it off at a finite point they have
to stay roughly balanced with each other. So this
tells us two important things: one is why we have a
kind of even balance in our race, and it's not that-
(But this was- but you did this with the
odd numbers, this is just prime numbers but it's)
(the same sort of principle)
- The key equation at
this point is to focus on what happens after we
do our log trick where all the stuff that remains
in the series is mostly primes. So what I could
say is, if we kick out all the prime powers
those- they don't actually amount to that much.
They converge absolutely, um and in fact they
have to be just bounded by some constant. And so
we could say if we ignore all the prime powers
we would have the sequence which sometimes you're
adding a prime, sometimes you're subtracting it, and
because it equals just a constant, just some number,
we can know that neither one of those camps blows
up much faster than the other. However, all of the
nuance for who's winning the race happens when
we really think hard about what happens to those
prime powers. Here's the like intuition - it is not
a proof - but here's the vague intuition for why you
might expect 3 mod 4 to be winning this race even
if you didn't start performing the race. If you
knew some analytic number theory, you had a strong
familiarity with the series, your prediction might
be I'm going to put my money on horse number
3. And how do I want to draw this? I'm going to
kind of have two buckets here; this is going to
be all of the stuff that we're adding in our sum
and then this is going to be all of the stuff that
we're subtracting. And we're just going to kind
of- what kind of things are we adding? What kind of
things are we subtracting? So the stuff that we're
adding, it's all of the primes which are 1 above
a multiple of 4 so- or rather the reciprocals of
those. So 1/5, 1/13, 1/17 -
these are the kind of things that we're adding. But
there's also some squares of primes that we're
adding: in fact critically the square of every
prime. Because even if you started from someone who
is going to be a negative, like -1/3,
once we look at the square term corresponding
to it it's something that we're adding.
So also in this camp of things that we're adding
is you have things like one half of 1 over 9,
or you also have things like one half of 1
over 25, or one half of 1 over 49. So
all of the primes are represented here with their
squares. And then in terms of the cubes, those ones
are also kind of accounted for but only the ones
which are one above a multiple of 5. So for
example 5 cubed is going to make it in, 1
over 125, but uh 3 cubed is actually
something that we subtracted so it's accounted
for in the other one. And maybe I'll even write
that over here, so we've got -1/3 by
1 over 27. This is- the point I want to make I
guess is if we look at this negative bucket - I'll
also write up in the top - also subtracting all
of the primes associated with things that are
3 above a multiple of 4. So we're subtracting
1/3, subtracting 1/7, subtracting 1/11.
What I want you to notice is how all of
the all of the even powers necessarily end up in
this positive bucket. So we also have you know 1/4
outside of 1/81 - all of the even powers end up here.
This gives a bias in some sense in the direction
of our adding bucket. So a priori, if we just say
looking at all of these terms what might we
we expect? We'd say, well, there's this little bit
of a bias for those in the adding bucket to just
have more numbers. If there were always the same
amount of numbers 1 above a multiple of 4 and
3 above a multiple of 4, because of those powers of
the primes that show up here, that gives a little
bit of added weight to this positive bucket. So if
we know that we actually want these terms to be
roughly evenly balanced, in the sense that they're
canceling each other out so much that they get to-
I mean the natural log of pi/4, it's a very small
number but the critically is it's a constant, it's
not like something that suggests one half of
this uh plus/minus bucket is going to tend off
to infinity. It means in order to make up for the
fault that they get by not getting of the any of
the fourth powers or any of the squares or any
of the sixth powers, we need just a little bit more
primes to start with, a little bit more that are in
this um 3 mod 4 bucket. Again, it's not a proof, but
that's where you might get this little intuition
that uh in order for this equation to balance out
you need a little leg up in that second camp. What
this would suggest is that there should be a bias
for 3- team 3 to stay in the lead more, there should
be a bias where there'll always be a few more
um primes that are mod 3 to make up for this uh
imbalance that they get once you introduce the
powers. But the- what you might expect is saying how
often is it the case that they are in the lead? If
we're watching this horse race, is it the case that
after some amount of time team 3 always stays in
the lead there on thereafter? Okay that's a little
bit strong. The softer consideration, which was the
conjecture made, is that the proportion of numbers
for which when you look at everything up to that
um the team 3 is in the lead tends to be closer
and closer to 100% as you look at more and more
numbers. So as this horse race is proceeding,
and you widen and widen your glance, you say
at various different checkpoints on their track a
vast majority of those checkpoints should be ones
where team 3 is in the lead. Now interestingly
that's not true; and if you look at what's the
percentage of numbers where team 3 was in the
lead on your way up it kind of toggles. It's
always very very big it's- you know 99%, 98%, close
to 100% but forever and forever it just sort of
wanders around and it doesn't approach anything.
Let's say you look at the first billion numbers.
You might notice that as we look at the race up to
that billion numbers, 99.5% of the time team
3 was in the lead; but uh there was some times that
team 1 was in the lead. Then you might ask, okay
what if I looked at the first trillion numbers,
the first quadrillion numbers. You might expect,
oh when I look at the first quadrillion then
it's 99.99% of the time that team 3 is in the
lead - that's not true. As you look at it then, you
know, maybe it's like 98% of the time that team 3
is in the lead. So they do trade off but there's
a clear bias for team 3, and the question is, you
know, how often do they trade off? And uh turns
out if you measure in a slightly different way-
so we're going to change the rules of the
race, where rather than counting each prime
um exactly you kind of discount them
by the- the reciprocal of that prime.
If- for the sake of the proofs I guess that must
have made it uh easier to prove, but it turns out
the team 3 will tend to be in the lead, as you
look at more and more numbers it's in the lead
99.59% of the time. So as you look at bigger and
bigger numbers it tends to be the case, with the
appropriate metric, that this is the amount of
time the team 3 is in the lead. So it's it's
almost always in the lead but not almost always
in the usual mathematician sense of the phrase.
Because usually when they say 'almost always' they
mean like 100% uh or it tends to 100%. So instead
it's in the normal human way of using the word
almost, almost always uh the case that uh team 3
is in the lead. But it is not such a clean fact
that it's just 100% or 0.
- (Does it ever get to)
(a point where it will be in the lead forever or?)
- No
- (So no matter where you are in the number line)
(team 1 has always got another moment in the
front coming?)
- Exactly, team 1 will always have
a chance. And in fact in this metric, as you look at
bigger and bigger swaths, it has 0.5%
of the time it'll be up there.
- (It's the Little EngineThat Could)
- Yes yes it really is, it really is.
(It's the tortoise!)
- It is the tortoise, slow and steady um every now and then it beats the
hare - even if the hare seems systematically better.
Thanks for watching this video. If you want
to see more from Grant you probably already
watch his channel 3Blue1Brown, there'll be
links in all the usual places. I'd also like
to say thank you to Numberphile's Patreon
supporters who make it possible for me to
travel and have the time to meet with people
like Grant and make these videos. If you'd like